this capsule we will discuss the case where
our algorithm must take some
decisions in real time so we saw
that the max mini sentry box allows
make decisions that are optimal
however, still slow enough
binds them to the pruning alfa beta that allowed
to accelerate a little the algorithm the
mini map booth
unfortunately in practice it happens
often it's not enough and we have to
so make decisions that will
having to be a perfect to satisfy
some time constraints so
maybe someone tells me that
of applications maybe in a
competition must not take more than 60
seconds to choose which game which
decision take some moves
to do in the game
and ben if we have an algorithm that is
such as an implementation that is
as we can explore 10 minutes by
second
it gives us a budget of 60 minutes
sorry if 5000 by park where eventually
we have to make money and so if
we give ourselves constraints like that
comment is what can happen
still make decisions that
are not too bad
therefore failing to be optimal which will
maybe still good enough for
succeed in gaining dangerous so the
projecting gold consists of two things
the first thing is we are going to cut
the research is to say that we will
not necessarily go one
total exploration for example the watchtower
pruning alphabet time we will not do
the complete exploration that we should
do normally we will cut the
research
when one could make one's limits and
in fact the depth of tears that we are going
to afford to explore
there are other techniques the others
approaches that are discussed in the
pound of euros out of the nine that you
would you go to consult if you want in
learn more so the first thing
it is to say we will cut the search
for example by limiting the depth of
the soul and then we will have to compensate
the fact that we do not explore until the end
all naked in the soul so we count
does not always happen
exploration at nodes that are of a
fine or else compensated by developing
a function of eristic evaluations and
its purpose is essentially the same
thing that in the paintings is said it's going
give an estimate of the calculation
do not confuse that we have not done yet
ie in this case we are going
estimate the utility that would have been obtained
if we had done a complete search
up to nine names up to ends
of part the difference with the stars
it's only with logistic star
allowed to guide that we are
explored first then eventually
in fact we will be a place that is eleven
optimal but also in this case
the way forgiveness reach the path
optimal in that if our function
of evaluations rustic she goes downright
replaced by the calculation that we would have to
to do otherwise it says she'll
replace the calculation of the minimum value
max of a draw to make a species of
cash prediction that would have happened
if I continued the game there until
the end so we can see on a little
as an estimate of the chance that a
state two parts that we reached even
possibly a victory
I will give two examples of function
of eristic evaluations there for
maybe the concept a little more concrete
for the game of chess
a typical assessment function we
will use it's going to be a sum
weighted of fisher or in French
features each shea butter stick and
a clue on an element can be
beneficial beneficial or negative to revisit
the configuration of the current player so
to give a typical example
we will note as function fdn that
could be the number of reindeer that the
player max 1 on the game so we know
also that white pawns are
mastered by mac players are
seized per day max so the number of
reindeer used by the max player who
are still on the board
- the reign name of the mino player yet
on the chessboard so among other things this
would be a number equal to 1
if the max player still had to reindeer
but the player did not have to
reindeer 0 if both still have their
ingredients could reindeer then - well
it is rather the player mines who in
Corsican with reindeer and their masks virgin
and we will weight the importance of this
characteristic by a weight that will
number is it so in this case it
could be new so that's it
would say is that the quality of the
configuration of chichis if it was the
first case that I mentioned earlier
know that it's the max day that in
Corsican to reindeer but the player mines the
so the quality of that would be an x
because if it's the opposite it's up to
to say that it was the mines player who
still had his queen
but in this case it would be worth less 9
w 1 time f1 - we would give less then
we could calculate full of evaluation
like that of the quality of the chessboard
for the max player basically more
normal posit and more is good for them
max players and there we could
design and many features
like that there are put together but
with their weighting is so there is
a whole search space both
rustico functions one could have
explored and his long or an expert must
think about finding good functions
characteristics then also to find
good weight values ​​that
would have good
performances
I could imagine
learning techniques for
allow a player to improve himself
even to find good values
weights w given the critics
fixed by playing several parts and on
cd notion that we will start
explore later in others
capsules when we talk between
other learning then
reinforcement learning
function examples a devaluation
heuristic this for the tick to toe that
could work well that would be the
name to avenge columns and diagonal who
are currently available for the
max player minus the same thing but for
the player comes so for example here
for this grid if for the day max one
has six columns hexagonal range
available as his like that like
like this like that and then like that
so these are bothered diagonal columns
which could possibly accommodate
series of 3 x so when 6 players max
1 suppose they use the beds x
is the opposite for the player for the
player mines
we rather have four columns range
hexagonal available this one here
this one is that there is no
diagonal because of his background we have
our example here that I hope in
exercise so that's actually it's
a figure that is going to be more and more
high depending on the quality of the
layout of the grid since
intuitively then orange and the pantyhose
diagonal of more opportunities for the
player eventually to come to
place a series of x or europe for
a mac under mines in the grid and
finally before finishing would like
mention the notion of generalization
random actions how does that
we apply them we adapt our
algorithms to allow games that
for example would involve launching
of a dea to determine what is the
next action so there is one aspect
random stochastic
the solution is actually relatively
simple all we will do is that
in our grave we will shake some knots
chance that you match by
example at the launch of rld and not door
what random aspect and in our
mini max algorithm we will replace the
calculate the value of the mini max where we are going
adapt it to calculate rather a mini
max hope finally a utility
hope associated with each state and therefore
we have an illustration of a graph where we
would have an imac what would have two
successors associated with two actions there
every action to involve a certain
aspect of luck that would say that with a
because if a probity of 90 for that
we would arrive at this success and also
with a quality 2.1 so 10 for that
we would not be able to get there sooner
ok so now we have three types of
max luck and mines and and four knots
if we count the nodes of the states
so ends up in this case we will not
calculate a utility or a min value
max 5 for your calculations and a utility or
by the mini max was hoping so everything
that we actually change in our
definition of the mini max hope that's
that in addition to the three conditions that
had before knowing 1 1 the terminal 1 the
mac are wet
we now have a calculation to do for
9 years old and for 9 years old
do a max on successors or a
of course the successors we will do a
m on successors weighted by the
probability of reaching each
successor from the 1st stream and
so we're going to do a kind of average
weighted mini max associated with each
successors and to do the math
from the mini max to the root we would have a
running a bit similar your
exploration depth similar to this
we saw in the minimax algorithm where
we would reach each of the children who
have shown we would spread the mini max
up until you reach the root
to get our mini max hope at
beginning of the game